تخيل ان تسافر من اقصى شمال الارض لاقصى
جنوبها في ساعتين فقط الخيال هذا قد يصبح
واقعا بفضل دراسه حديثه تقترح السفر
بالصاروخ بدلا من الطائرات هيئه الطيران
المدني في المملكه المتحده تختبر حاليا
قدره البشر على تحمل هذا النوع من الرحلات
فالصاروخ سيطير نحو الفضاء وعند الاقتراب
من وجهته سيعود مجددا للارض الركاب
سيجربون شعور رواد الفضاء وقد يعانون في
مرحله تسارع صاروخ الاولى من اعراض كصعوبه
في التنفس وفقدان مؤقت بالرؤيه واحتمال
حدوث تجلطات بالدم في 30 ثانيه الاولى
الرحله من لندن الى سن تستغرق اليوم
بالطائره نحو 22 ساعه لكنها بالصاروخ لن
تزيد على ساعتين اما التكلفه فستكون
30000 دولار في البدايه وقد تنخفض لاحقا
مع زياده الطلب فهل انتم مستعدون للسفر
بالصاروخ